A cost of living crisis is unfolding in America's major cities.
We can't afford to live in this city if you're a working class New Yorker.
The problems are acute in downtown Manhattan.
One-bedroom units are renting for nearly $4,000 a month on average.
There's a reason people are willing to pay.
It drives you and it motivates you...
...and it keeps you hungry.
It keeps you always thinking...
...because, no matter what, you know there's somebody out there hustling more.
There's somebody thinking something new.
You can never become complacent.
That's what's so beautiful about this city.
People have returned to cities to see their friends and have a good time.
That's pushing rents to new highs in places like Los Angeles, Chicago...
...and cities across the Sun Belt.
While renters have returned, many commuters haven't...
...despite the return-to-office push...
...from major companies like Goldman Sachs and JP Morgan.
More days at home could help workers escape high city prices and long commutes,...
...but there could be a cost to that decision.
As prices keep rising across the country,...
...we ask, are American major cities like New York still worth it?